- [Mark] All right, Jasmine.
- Yes.
- [Mark] Welcome back.
- Hey.
- [Mark] So it's been quite a while,
I posted your video recently,
but that interview was actually
from probably the spring, right?
- [Jasmine] Yeah, it's been awhile.
- [Mark] It's been quite awhile, yeah.
So tell me what's going
on in your life now.
- Basically, I'm still like
on the street for whatnot.
I had a couple of run ins
with one of my ex pimps
or whatnot.
I tried to work it out with him,
but it got worse to where
he was choking me out,
to where I started foaming at the mouth,
trying to kill me,
threatening to go shoot my sister's house,
so when my daughter is, all type of stuff,
to where it was kind of hard
for me to leave him again.
And then finally when I
got away, he'll show up
to like different areas
that he knows I'm in
and he'll like hop out the car
and try to drag me in the car
and threatening me and all type of stuff.
But it took for him to go to
jail for a parole violation,
that's how it stopped.
- [Mark] Oh, that that'll do the trick.
- Yeah, so yeah but..
- [Mark] Good for you.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Your personality seems so soft
and sensitive, kindhearted and yet you're
working this..
- Hard life.
- [Mark] This very hard, cold.
- It really is.
- [Mark] Heartless life.
You never know what we go through,
a lot of people don't
understand, you know?
- [Mark] How do you survive?
You don't seem as thick skinned
as maybe some of the other girls are.
- To be honest, I don't
know how I survive.
I don't know,
just being out here and
doing all this stuff
and I go through a lot of
stuff dealing with clients
and I've, you know what I'm saying?
I still to this day, I
don't know how I survive.
Maybe I'm lucky, you know but,
it gets scary sometimes
'cause you never know who's
car you're going to get in,
if you're going to make it out that car,
you never know, and that's the
scary part of it, you know?
- [Mark] Yeah, you need the money so-
- Exactly, yeah 'cause fast money,
easy money, but like I said,
it comes with consequences, you know?
Like you never know.
- [Mark] It seems to
me like there's no way
your soul can't take the hit,
doing this kind of work.
I don't believe humans are meant to
just do this kind of work.
- Sometimes..
- [Mark] You eventually get depressed,
or on drugs or something.
- Yeah, I'm not going to lie,
when I started doing this
and not until I started
showing and everything,
in order for me to go outside
and deal with the clients,
I have to get high to numb that,
to numb it to deal with them.
I couldn't go outside sober or anything,
I had to get high.
- [Mark] Yeah and now you're pregnant now.
How far along are you?
- I'm about three to four months.
- [Mark] So using drugs
while you're pregnant.
- In the beginning before I was showing,
yeah I'm not going to lie
because it's hard, you know?
- [Mark] And that was crystal meth?
But you've stopped now?
- I've stopped yeah.
- [Mark] Good.
- Yeah, but like I said, it's really hard.
Like, so I would just numb it just kill
that feeling and to deal with them,
I can't deal with them sober.
- [Mark] Do you,
tell me about your
clients, your customers.
Are they, do you respect these guys?
- I mean to a certain extent, I do,
But some, for example, I'm really sweet
and I get some clients that will be,
kind of okay in the beginning
and they end up doing something dumb,
like trying to like,
one guy had pulled a gun out on me
and took my money back,
and one guy tried to stab me, you know?
And I still try to go outside
with a good attitude and be nice
and you know, but it's always
that one that will like,
you know, have me thinking,
okay maybe all everyone's the same,
to where I get scared sometimes
but like I said, I need money.
So I got to deal with the
consequences, you know of that,
but yeah...
- [Mark] And then to
quit this line of work
and go get
a regular job,
- Nine to five.
- [Mark] Nine to five job,
is that even a possibility?
now you're going to be,
this is your first child?
- Huh?
- [Mark] Do you have children?
- I have four.
- [Mark] You have four.
And you're raising?
- They're not with me right now.
- [Mark] They're not with you.
You're hoping to raise this one?
- Yeah, I do.
But it's going to take a lot.
- [Mark] To get a nine
to five job would be..
- See the situation with me,
as far as like, you know,
you need identification,
you need all that stuff to get jobs
or resume, all that, I
don't have any of that
my credentials right now,
because I wasn't born in the hospital,
my mom had me at home,
to where now there's no birth certificate.
And I had to go through
the whole process of doing
the labor through registration,
that takes a long time to
get a birth certificate.
And it's a lot, you know
and sometimes I just want to give it up,
that's why I just do do this
because it's easier, fast money
and you know,
I don't got to go through
the runaround with it.
- [Mark] Yeah, and how much
will you make in a night?
- [Jasmine] It all depends,
on a good night maybe two, 300.
Sometimes I won't even make
that on a bad night, 100.
- [Mark] Oh really?
- [Jasmine] Sometimes you're out there
for a long time just to make-
- [Mark] It's cold right now too.
- [Jasmine] Yeah just to make 100 dollars
it takes a very long time sometimes,
you never know if you're going to really
get your date or anything.
- [Mark] I think you're the
first girl that's been honest.
- [Jasmine] Yeah,
you have to, tell the truth you know?
- [Mark] Some of them say
they're making 1500 so.
- [Jasmine] Yeah, I'm just being honest,
ain't no way in hell,
whoever told you that they're lying,
it's really hard out there.
- [Mark] What emotions do
you struggle with the most?
You get anxious or depressed or angry?
- [Jasmine] As far as what?
- [Mark] Just something-
- I get depressed-
- [Mark] Like I would get
depressed if I was doing it.
- I get depressed, I'm not going to lie,
I do get depressed a lot.
I very seldom get angry,
you gotta really make me
mad for me to get angry,
but more so depressed.
Yeah, 'cause I was like
why my life had to turn
out like this, but you know
shit, stuff happens, you know?
So yeah.
- [Mark] And what would you like to see,
I mean, do you know who
the father is of your baby?
- Not really, I'm just be honest
and I wouldn't put my bins out there
but I'm just telling you the truth,
I really don't know.
- [Mark] Did that happen
with one of your clients?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] So you were having
sex without a condom?
- Not necessarily a few
times the thing broke
and I didn't know at first
you know what I'm saying?
And I got like bigger and I didn't know
I had a little cycle, I
didn't think nothing of it,
but then I started showing
and I'm like oh yeah, pregnant.
So, and I don't believe in abortion,
so yeah, I'm ashamed but
I'm not ashamed, you know?
- [Mark] Yeah.
What helps you survive this life?
I mean, there's, what
do you tell yourself,
or what do you, how do you just,
you seem to be like if,
I don't know you well, but
your personality seems like,
man, this would really
affect you in a major way.
- What helps me?
Like I said, back then, I ain't gonna lie,
the drugs was helping to numb it
and I just thinking about my future,
I'm going to be getting,
I'm gonna have my kids,
and just, you know, stuff like that
'cause if you go outside
with a negative mind,
it's not good, you know?
- [Mark] You have no choice.
- Yeah, but yeah.
- [Mark] Refresh my memory.
Your childhood you had,
was there abuse in your childhood?
- It was,
a lot of abuse, like my foster mother
she was the ordained minister like I said
and she used to always tell me how
I was going to become a prostitute.
- [Mark] Oh, that's right, yeah.
- How I was going to die early age,
how my family was going to disown me
and how dudes were going to beat me up
and ever since I left her home,
everything's happened
from being a prostitute,
coming close to death.
My family does disown me,
I'm like the black sheep of my family
and I came close to death,
a few times, so yeah.
- [Mark] Kind of paves the
way for this doesn't it?
- I've been shot in my face,
I have bug shot to my face.
I've been stabbed twice,
all type of stuff.
- [Mark] It's a horrible life isn't it?
- Is it, like I said, it's scary,
I've had friends that
I know in the lifestyle
that got murdered all
type of stuff, doing this
and like I said, you never know.
- [Mark] The heart, one of the things
that just hit me recently,
I mentioned in some of the other talks
with some of the girls I've done recently,
that just realizing that every trick,
every cop, every other girl
on the street, the pimps,
everybody that you're
interacting with is on the take.
They're all up to no
good, they're all kind of-
- Ulterior motives.
- [Mark] Ulterior motives,
they're looking out for
themselves and not you
and nobody's really.
- Pretty much.
- [Mark] Help you out.
- And that's the part that
sucks because you think people
are your friends out here,
it's like they're not your friend,
they're just there to see
what they can get out of you.
And when you don't got
it, then that's when
they wanna act funny and
turn their back on you
and that's the part that sucks you know?
Yeah, it's hard, very very hard,
I just try to be strong
and as much as I can,
but sometimes it's hard for
me to even do that you know?
Yeah.
This world is cruel.
Very, very cruel.
- [Mark] Is that how you see the world?
Do you have friends?
- I have associates, I don't
call everybody my friend
because everybody ain't
your friend, you know?
Yeah.
- [Mark] All right,
Jasmine, thank you so much
for coming in again and
good luck with your baby.
- Thank you.
- [Mark] It's a crazy
way for a pregnant woman
to be making money.
- Yeah, people will be
looking at me crazy,
but yeah.
- [Mark] All right, thank you.
All right, Jasmine,
so we spoke a couple of weeks ago.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And I'd been thinking
about your situation a lot
since then, you have a baby coming.
- I do yeah.
- [Mark] And you're working the street.
- Yep.
- [Mark] And you don't
have any family to help you
with the baby when it comes?
- I have family but they're not involved.
I don't get along with my family.
- [Mark] So you're really on your own.
- Yep.
- [Mark] And as you
explained that the father
of the child is not in the pictures.
- Nope, not at all.
- [Mark] What stops you from getting
off the street and doing,
getting a job and ?
- Basically, my credentials
as far as like my birth
certificate and stuff,
when my mother had me she
didn't have me in the hospital,
she had me at home and then I was taken to
Centinela Hospital, but
there's no record of it.
It's just a paper that my
foster mom had that said
my mom's name when I was
brought in, how much I weighed
but it's a copy, but no one will take it.
So now, like every time I
go to the Hall of Records,
they said that I don't
have a birth certificate
and I would have to go
through the whole process
of doing a deliberate registration,
but in the forums, you need to either,
they want me to put the
location where my mom had me
and I don't know 'cause
my my mom died in 93.
So as far like knowing like where she,
like apartments or anything, I don't know.
- [Mark] So you're destined
to work the streets forever
unless you sort this out?
- Yeah it has been kind of
frustrating trying to figure it
out and then calling around,
getting the runaround.
- [Mark] There must be some
solution to this that..
- Yeah, I tried and then it's,
I've tried so many times
to where I get frustrated,
and I want to give up you know?
But it's a lot I have to do, yeah.
- [Mark] So you had a pimp at one point.
- I did.
- [Mark] Early on in your career,
is it what the tattoo on
your forearm is about?
- Yes it is
and he had his homeboy do it,
brand me and of course I can't say no,
because if I tell him no,
he gets mad and wants to
be beat me up or, you know?
- [Mark] So you were
forced to get that tattoo?
- Exactly.
- [Mark] It's big.
- It is, yeah I know.
- [Mark] You're lucky some of the girls
have it on their face.
- I know, he was gonna
make me do it right here,
yeah he didn't, he just had
them do it right here, yeah.
- [Mark] And you know,
how do they get you
into that relationship?
- Sweet talk, or they act like
they pretend like they're your friends,
or like, they just want to
just kick it or whatever
and they sometimes trick
girls into becoming their,
you know, working prostitute or whatever.
It starts off cool in the beginning
and then it gradually gets into,
oh you gotta work for me, or you know,
trying to, get you into
it, it's kind of weird.
- [Mark] So a typical night
you would go out in the street
and you'd make-
- A certain amount of money,
or a quota as they say.
- [Mark] And how do
you deliver it to them?
- Just basically I text him
or meet him on a backstreet
and hop in the backseat
and give him the money
and then he'll drive off
somewhere on another backstreet
and let you out again.
- [Mark] And you give him all the money.
- Or sometimes the guy
search you, they search
if you got it in your wig,
they'll pull your wig off,
if you have it anywhere else,
they'll still search you.
It's called tucking, so yeah.
They don't like that.
- [Mark] So crazy.
Luckily you got out of your situation.
- Yeah (indistinct).
- [Mark] But a lot of girls can't.
- No, some girls get killed by their pimp,
a lot of girls, we got through a lot,
you never know like some
dudes are real crazy.
Like I had a friend, her pimp killed her
she wanted to leave and
it was all on Facebook,
so yeah, it's hard sometimes.
- [Mark] So, you know,
I keep thinking about your
story since that last talk,
if I was to somehow help you
with some of your expenses,
do you think you could I mean,
I'm just trying to keep the child,
keep you from losing the child
and maybe you can somehow
get your birth certificate,
get your life together a little bit.
Does that sound like something
you might want to try?
- Yes, especially with like stability,
that's my main issue.
- [Mark] Yeah, so I can help
you a little bit financially
with that and then I'll do my part,
but you're gonna have to do some
- Footwork, right
I appreciate that.
- [Mark] On your end as well
but your story is just gonna,
this child's life is going to be sad
if you don't get something together.
- Yeah I don't want that,
that's just part that's going to be like,
it's going to suck if I
don't get us together,
it's kinda hard, you know?
- [Mark] I think the honesty that you,
you're one of the most
honest girls I've talked to
that works the streets.
- I just tell the truth, I can't lie.
- [Mark] It just made me wanna,
I think my viewers is same thing,
when someone's honest,
they like them much more
they're much more easy to..
- It's better than tell
the truth about things
than hide it, if people
not ready to tell them
what we go through then
sugarcoat, or, you know
come up with excuses for them,
I just want to be just
truthful and tell you the real
uncut, everything about
everything, so yeah.
- [Mark] All right, so we'll talk further
about how to do this,
but I'll help you a little
bit financially here to,
so you don't have to maybe,
you don't have to work the
streets so much or at all
and maybe you can do some
things that'll prepare you for..
- [Jasmine] I appreciate it.
- [Mark] It helped a lot
that you told me you're not
using any longer and
that's a big part of it.
- [Jasmine] Yeah.
- [Mark] That's a big part of it for me.
- [Jasmine] Thank you.
- [Mark] All right, well
I wish you the best of luck.
- Thank you.
- [Mark] And I guess we'll talk again.
- Okay.
- [Mark] Thanks Jasmine.
- All right, thanks.